Russian President Vladimir Putin has
referred to his country's invasion of
Ukraine as a war for the first time and
not merely a special military operation
in a press conference Putin said Moscow
was striving for peace and was open to
negotiations to end the war the
president has long insisted that Russia
was not Waging War on Ukraine and the
use of the word to describe the conflict
has effectively been outlawed
now here's what he had to say
our goal is not to spin the flywheel of
military conflict but on the contrary to
end this war we strive for this and we
will continue to strive we will strive
for an end to this and the sooner the
better
Putin finally calling The Invasion what
it is a war but how are we to understand
this was this just a slip of the tongue
or deliberate I put that question to DW
reporter Maria katamaze
well I would say that it's a big deal uh
just to remind you after Moscow
introduced fake law legislation this
March the wood War has been essentially
made illegal to even be pronounced or
written well if Putin's wooding was
delivered it may indicate that the whole
conflict is entering at least in his
mind a bigger and more significant phase
uh the kremlin's logic behind that can
be we wanted it to be a short military
operation aiming aiming at specific
military Targets in Ukraine in order to
save russian-speaking population in the
donbass region but for the past few
months the rhetoric is not just about
saving Russian speaking people in
Ukraine but possibly about the
resistance to the whole NATO block so
it's interesting that the world war has
been part of a state TV vocabulary for a
while now when talking about NATO's
proxy war in Russia well Putin and the
state media is essentially trying to
um to make Russians um believe that it's
a faithful moment for the country its
survival is at stake because the Hostile
West wants to divide once a divided and
weak Russia so this can be an
explanation why to why he used a
stronger and more accurate word this
time but Maria authorities had been
cracking down on ordinary Russians and
media organizations for not sticking to
the official party line to Putin's line
of using the term special military
operations so what consequences will
Putin's use of the word War have
well it may sound funny and ridiculous
but Saint Petersburg opposition figure
Nikita effect demanded a legal
investigation against Vladimir Putin for
using the world war in his speech
according to euphera for thousands have
already been prosecuted for calling a
Russian invasion of Ukraine a war and
Putin is not an exemption from the law
of course we cannot talk seriously about
any legal consequences for the Russian
president but for their War resistors
and the Kremlin critique critics be it
activists journalists or opposition
leaders the danger is quite real still